so today I'm delighted to introduce our
first um invited speaker is Dao Aquila
um there has also been
um as well as being invited and I'll
tell his background
um he's also
um in the symbolic systems program has
been an Adjunct professor and has been
involved with some students in that role
as well but in his invited role he's
originally from the Netherlands where he
even learned some logic among other
things back in the old days but in more
recent times he's been
um a prominent
um deep learning researcher for a number
of years he worked at
um Facebook now meta in the fair unit
and was involved in various ideas
including retrieval augmented Generation
Um after that he then spent some time at
hugging face he's become interested in
looking at multimodal models which is
what he's going to be talking about
today and we welcome Dara it's great to
have you
thank you very much
foreign
yes uh yeah thanks everyone for coming I
understand that you get points for being
here so you're not really here for me
but uh uh thanks for coming anyway so
I'm going to talk about multimodal deep
learning uh it's gonna have an NLP focus
of course that's for discourse but it's
also because otherwise I would really be
talking for uh many more hours than I
have time for here so I'll try to really
keep it focused on on the things that I
think will be most useful for you to
learn and so the first thing you should
understand is that this whole concept of
multimodality is is kind of ill-defined
actually
um so if you go to the dictionary you'll
see that it means having or involving
several modes or modalities or Maxima
um and and so what mode here really
means is so it could be mode in the very
generic sense or it could be a very
precise sense of the mode of a
statistical distribution
um and so depending on the paper you're
reading in some cases people really mean
this statistical sense in other cases
people really mean this sort of very
vague concept of a modality where it
really means the type of information
that you're getting so an example of
modality in that case is an image or
speech signal or audio in general or
even affection so smell or or things
like that so in this uh lecture we're
just going to focus mostly on text
because this is an NLP course and we're
going to focus on images mostly as the
other modality to to keep it simple
all right so why does it matter why do
we care about multi-modality
um and so there are a couple of really
good reasons in general for this uh the
the first one is is about faithfulness
so if you look at how we humans
understand the world how we make sense
of what happens in the world uh that is
very multimodal uh right so we we
perceive the world not just using Vision
uh or just audio but we synthesize
information across all of these
different modalities and that's how we
understand the world and each other
um there's also a very practical uh
argument for doing it it's because the
internet is multimodal right so if you
go to I don't know uh like Facebook or
something like that like it rarely
happens that it's just text or just an
image there's usually a combination of
multiple modalities and then the the
final good reason uh that we're just
starting to hit now if you're if you're
really following where the field is
going we're kind of running out of Text
data for these large language models so
uh one interesting way to uh keep
scaling on the data side is to make use
of all of these other modalities right
so if you can have your language model
also watch all of the videos of cats in
the world it's going to understand the
concept of catch cat much better and
that's what we want to have in these
models we want them to understand the
world in the same way that humans
understand it
um so right now multimodality is really
one of the main frontiers of this New
Foundation model uh drives that were all
in right now
there's a thing called the mcgurk effect
let's see if it loads up uh but uh so uh
what what we'll see when this loads is
uh this guy over here and uh we'll have
the same audio effect uh being played so
the audio is exactly the same and this
man is going to say something like
and so you're hearing a b there I think
if you look at my mouth because that's
what I said uh but if you then change
the video to where he says
with exactly the same audio you're going
to hear the other version
um so unfortunately I can't really like
swap in the different audio here so you
have to trust me for it we might
suddenly start hearing a guy saying
all right
um so um uh multimodal applications so
when we have multiple modalities we can
do all kinds of uh interesting things
and as I said most of the use cases we
have on the internet they're all
multimodal
um and there are some really kind of
obvious things we would be interested in
if we have information from these
different data sources right from
different modalities uh so obviously we
might want to do retrieval so maybe
given a bit of text we want to find the
right image or maybe given some image we
want to find the right text for it so we
can match them up obviously we can also
do this in a generative setting so then
we have image captioning which you've
probably heard of we can do text to
image generation so that's image
synthesis and so stable diffusion
everybody in the audience here has
probably seen that then we could do a
visual question answering where we have
an image and text and then we need to
generate some new text we have
multimodal classification where we have
image syntax and we need to have a label
for example whether something is hate
speech or not and then in general we
want to be able to have a richer
understanding of information which means
that we combine images and text and then
use it for Downstream applications that
require better understanding or better
Generation
Um so this field really is super hot
right now uh so there's this uh this
nice paper title I predict that this
paper is going to do really well in
terms of citations just because it has
such a sideable title I think a lot of
people are not actually going to read it
and so I mean I've been in this field
for quite a while now and people have
been saying this for a really long time
I think Chris would agree that so for
decades people have been saying that
multimodal is the next big thing uh but
now it's really true I think
all right so uh the outline for uh what
we're going to be talking about so first
I'm going to tell you a little bit about
early models then we're going to do a
bit of a deep dive on some of the
specifics then we're gonna go over a
particular type of fusion contrastive
models or Lake Fusion then we're gonna
go through a little bit of the history
of multimodal foundation models then
we're going to talk a little bit about
evaluation a little bit about other
modalities and then I'll make some
predictions for the future and hopefully
maybe give you some cool research ideas
or things to talk or think about
all right so
um obviously like there's a lot of work
that happened before deep learning but I
think if you want to start from like the
Deep learning Revolution and what was
happening in images and text then a good
starting point is for example Wasabi uh
or device uh or Richard zoker who you
who you've probably heard of has done
some really cool early work in this that
really pioneered a lot of these ideas uh
and the basic uh gist of this is that we
have a vision model on the one hand we
have a language model so this really I
mean the first lecture of this course I
think was about word embeddings right so
that's just your basic word embedding
model and now we need to figure out how
to align them in the same multimodal
space so the way you do that is you get
some sort of similarity metric right a
score function or like a kernel function
if you're thinking about this from a
support Vector machine literature
perspective and now you need to figure
out uh in a Max margin or margin loss
um uh how you want to align these two
points in your embedding space right so
things that are similar you want to
bring them closer together things that
are not you want to bring them further
apart and if you do that in this
multimodal embedding space that means
that you can do interesting cross-modal
transfer where you can take the word
embedding for something like Auto or
like horse and then you can find close
images in the embedding space to that
thing and now now you've solved the
retrieval problem so this is a really
nice early application and I think a lot
of the stuff that I'm going to talk
about in the in the early slides you're
going to see this income over and over
again you're going to see it get kind of
reinvented with fancier models but it's
basically all the same stuff
um so you can do cross modal transfer
where you have images and text but you
can also combine them together so that
you get a multimodal word embedding uh
and so this uh just gives you a more
accurate representation of how humans
understand words word meaning because
when we think about the word Moon uh or
cat or something we can go to Wikipedia
and read that a cat is a small
carnivorous mammal that people like to
keep as pets or we can just go and look
at pictures of cats and now we
understand what a cat is right and I
would argue actually that for a lot of
people the picture of the cats is much
closer to the meaning of the concept of
cat
um so uh some some early work where
people were trying to do this is from
Rooney at all where they did multimodal
distribution or semantics using this
very uh elegant approach called bag of
visual words so just like who has heard
of bag of visual words
very few people okay so it's it's
surprisingly simple and so I kind of
like it it's nicely elegant so you take
a picture of a moon in this case I think
you can see it in the back too right so
uh we use an algorithm like sift uh to
find interesting key points so it's sort
of where the difference between the
pixels and the pixels next to it where
that difference is Big those are sort of
the spots you want to be looking at
and for each of these key points you get
feature descriptors so relatively small
vectors like 32 dimensional events are
kind of on the on the implementation of
this and what you can do now with these
feature descriptors is you can cluster
them using k-means and then you assign
every one of these points uh so you can
count how often they occur right so in
this picture of the Moon we have like uh
actually the count is oh yeah so there
are three like red dots right so that's
why the Red Dot one is three so what
that gives you is a uh an idea of the
visual words very similar to the
original bag of words model that you
hopefully have heard about maybe in the
first lecture
um so that's the visual equivalent of
the textual thing
um and so if you do this and you then
concatenate or you apply sud to fuse the
information what you get is a word
embedding that is much more
representative of human meaning so you
know as reflected in the data sets that
people used to care about at the time so
after that there were a couple of people
me included who tried to take these
ideas and then really applied deep
learning to them so some of the very
early versions of this use convolutional
neural networks uh and then you can
transfer the features from uh your your
confnet and you take your word
embeddings which you've seen in the
first lecture uh and then you can
concatenate them now you have a
multimodal work vector or you can do
something slightly fancier so you've
seen the skip gram model you can also
try to do skip gram predictions onto
image features right so when you see
your work like cat in some contexts like
the cute little cat said on the Met then
when you see cat you also want to
predict cat pictures
so super easy ideas but it turned out
that this gives you much richer work
representations uh so that's kind of
cool but obviously words are very
limited what we really care about is not
words but sentences so uh then people
started really looking into sentence
representations and how can we figure
out uh how to get compositional
understanding in the sentence
representations and how to how do we
align that with images
um so the loss here is very similar to
what we saw with works and pictures but
now we just have a sentence encoder
right um and so there's some really cool
early papers from Andre karapati and
Richard Soaker also had some work here
um and then you know so the basic idea
is just that instead of having these
word embeddings we now have an lscm in
these papers or some other kind of
recurrent neural network or in the case
of this one recursive neural network and
then we try to align the features
together
um and so so these three or four papers
are actually very important than this
one by me is less important but it's
still kind of interesting because uh we
showed here that grounded sentence
representation so if you actually just
use this part here as a sentence encoder
for NLP tasks the ability to just
predict pictures from it already gives
you a really good sentence
representation right so so just by
predicting pictures you can sort of
imagine what things look like and that
gives you a really good meaning
representation which you can then
transfer to I don't know sentiment
classification or something else
um and then of course uh once we have
census encoders uh or then we also have
decoders and and so when the sequence to
sequence architecture came out which
you've probably also heard about in this
course uh what you can do instead of
having a text encoder for like your
Source language if you're doing machine
translation is you can plug in a confnet
uh instead of an lstm encoder and now
you can generate captions so that's
exactly what people did we used to have
all of these fancy diagrams in our
papers then where we explain the lstm
and how that works probably people don't
learn that anymore these days they do
yeah very good they might make a
comeback I think you know at some point
uh Transformers are going to go away
we'll see
um and uh so uh one of the things that
that people figured out in machine
translation very early on is that you
can do alignment of words between your
Source language and your target language
and you can do the same thing actually
with images right so if you want to
align a word in your uh in your
generated sequence with something in
your picture then you can do the same uh
use the same approach for that and that
approach of course is called attention
right so you know you've learned a lot
about detention probably in this course
and and so yeah that was one of the the
building blocks of these systems as well
where you can do very interesting things
uh and really see that when it has to
generate stop for the stop sign that is
really actually looking at the stop sign
right so there's a really cool alignment
going on there
um in these models
um and so the the final kind of early
model we should talk about a little bit
uh is Gans uh who here is sort of Gans
okay that's a lot a lot more than bag of
visual words I guess that makes sense
um and uh so so yeah the basic idea of
again is really that you have this
generator and discriminator and you want
to have the generator uh generate images
that the discriminator cannot
distinguish uh uh from uh so it cannot
distinguish fake and real images right
and if you do that you can actually
condition that on the piece of text uh
and then you can generate images uh
using some some uh text prompt right so
that's what what uh kind of the the
first versions of stable diffusion we're
doing things like this and you know it's
all the a natural progression to that
model
um
so those were the early models
um maybe do people have any like burning
questions about this or does this all
make sense
all right
so let's do a bit of a deeper dive then
on on in particular on features and
fusion so those are really the kind of
core building blocks for for all of this
multimodal stuff really but before we go
there maybe very briefly like if all of
this multimodal stuff is cool and sort
of useful and and doesn't look that
difficult you know like why aren't we
all doing multimodal things and so why
why do we focus on specific modalities
and I think there are a couple of
problems just to be aware of uh so one
is modalities can sometimes dominate
especially text is much more dominant
than Vision or audio in many use cases
right so uh you can already just have a
model that picks up on the tech signal
and basically learns to ignore the image
completely which actually happened
embarrassingly for visual question
answering we'll get to that so visual
question answering you could do that
without actually looking at the picture
um the additional modalities can add a
lot of noise so it makes your machine
learning problem more difficult uh you
don't always have full coverage right so
as I said if you look at Facebook posts
sometimes you have text sometimes you
have pictures sometimes you have both
but you don't have a guarantee that you
always have both so how do you deal with
that
um in many cases we just really weren't
ready it was too complicated to
implement stuff and also just in general
like how to design your model really to
uh to combine all the information is
actually quite complicated so in order
to to uh you know to maybe drive the
home that point home a little bit
um so featurizing text I guess we all
know how to do that by now especially
sort of in the age of Transformers and
before in lstm sorry we just said like
you have your batch by your secrets so
batch size by sequence length by
embedding size right so it's always like
a 3D tensor and that's how you encode
your textual information when you pump
it through your neural net
um and so with images it's like trickier
because you can just kind of look at the
patches but then if you do convolutions
you're kind of like shifting over the
image and then you're aggregating right
um and in many cases you don't really
want to be this uniform you want to have
something that actually looks at the
things in the picture right so this is
called region features where you would
use an object detector as a first step
for processing your image and then you
would have a confident backbone that
encodes the features for that particular
sub image like this guys like skateboard
or something it has its own like vector
representation right
um and then in terms of dense features
we now also have Vision Transformers so
we'll just very quickly go over that to
make sure we're on the same page so
there are all these models like YOLO is
a really good one if you haven't heard
of that yet uh so we're at YOLO V7 now I
think create I don't know uh so there's
a new one coming out every every other
like year or something but the basic
idea is that we get these bounding boxes
uh for things in the images right
actually segmentations with the bounding
boxes is what people tend to use and
they they have labels right so this is
labeled like Backpacker or something and
so you can do this as a pre-processing
step on your image to get a much richer
representation of what is really in that
image which you can then pump into your
system as we'll see later and and so
then how you encode the information that
is in these little bounding boxes or
actually in the image itself in general
we just use a standard comp net for that
and so this probably feels like super
obvious now but uh in 2014 when people
were starting to discover this it was
really very surprising that you could
just use off-the-shelf continent
features to really replace the entire
computer vision pipeline so people used
to do all of this very fancy
sophisticated stuff and people you know
spend decades on trying to refine this
and then it was all thrown away and
replaced by a confnet that does all of
that stuff for free
um and so the cool thing you get there
is that you can transfer very easily
across different tasks so you don't you
can have a very generic confidence and
then use it to all kinds of very
specialized uh things like spotting
buildings in Paris for example or
flowers or other stuff
um and then of course in the age of
Transformers
um how far how far we're already quite a
while and this is only the first
Transformer actually uh in the the slide
deck so uh you know we're making good
progress uh so Vision Transformers are
what we would use these days to encode
the images uh where you have these
flattened patches and then you would do
uh kind of the the standard birth
architecture maybe as you would know it
from this course and then you do
classification right so this is all like
a standard Transformer everything
standards except now your input here is
not words or tokens it's patches of an
image and then you classify that
all right so then we have a bunch of
features and now how do we combine the
information right so let's say we have
two vectors u and v uh so you know it
sounds easy right to how how we could
could combine them it turns out that
they're actually very many ways to
combine them so I I don't think it's
it's really useful to go over all the
different ways here
um but you can do very simple things
right so obviously like uh inner product
or similarity is what you would use if
you want to do cross-modal things so if
you want to embed things in the same
Vector space uh but you can do sort of
fancier uh projections on top or
different combinations that are kind of
linear uh or you can do multiplicative
things where you uh multiply the
components element wise or you do some
sort of gating over the different
features you can do attention you can do
fancier buy linear things you can do
very fancy compact bilinear things so
there there's really a wealth of
literature kind of on all the different
ways you can combine two vectors and and
so uh this is called multimodal fusion
and most of the literature on multiple
modality is essentially about this
question what is the best way to do
fusion and that's it
um so so I think within that discussion
it's maybe useful to distinguish between
different levels of fusion so you can do
it very early where basically you make
sure you have the different features and
then you just kind of uh in in the sort
of modern sense of attention you would
attend to everything in all the features
from the beginning you can first treat
them separately and then combine them or
you can treat them as completely
separate and then you only combine the
final scores right and so there's the so
that's kind of what we would call Early
fusion and then sort of my my invention
for calling the middle part would be
sort of middle fusion and then you have
late Fusion uh where you really just
combine the scores or the logits but you
don't really have any interaction
between the information from the
different modalities
um so you could do really fun stuff with
multimodal Fusion so this is a paper I
really like film
um where uh you have this sort of very
special uh
feature Maps this sort of f here and it
gets gets modulated by a multiplicative
Factor so this gamma and an additive
sort of bias Vector this beta and you
have a different one for every layer of
a resnet that is conditioned on some
encoding of the thing you're after uh so
in this case are there more cubes than
yellow things so we have some Vector
representation for that and we use that
Vector representation to modulate the
resnet blocks at every layer of the
confident
um so you know you can really do very
fun things where you're sort of
modulating one network with the other
one and really try to have them learn uh
as much as possible from that
all right so
um let's talk about late Fusion then so
late Fusion is what we would Now call
contrastive models uh but the basic idea
is that we have this similarity score so
we have the two kind of we process the
modalities completely independently and
then at the very end we do some
combination uh and the most famous uh
instance of that uh these days is clip
so who's heard of clip
okay so clip uh from openai and so it's
again exactly the same contrast of loss
that that we've seen in all these early
approaches
um it does kind of negative sampling uh
but then in batch so you just have a
batch you have two things that are
aligned right so like this the first
piece of text and the first image they
are aligned so this is the right answer
and I just want to make sure that I rank
this thing higher than all the
alternatives
right and I want to make sure I rank
this thing higher than all the
Alternatives so it's a very very simple
idea uh really really nothing special
about this architecture that that was
sort of invented here but what made this
uh thing so cool was first of all it was
Transformers and it was Transformers all
the way so your text encoder would be a
Transformer and your image encoder would
be a vit image encoder so also a
Transformer
um and it was trained on lots and lots
of web data so Alex Radford is really a
genius at creating very high quality
data sets and he he created I think 300
million image text pairs for this data
set trained a bigger model on on it than
people used to do and then we got this
amazing model out of it
um and so so uh moving away from the
words there to the sort of texts that
you would see on the internet right so
the caption uh for an image on the web
it's not going to say dog or cat it's
going to say a photo of a cat doing
something something right so uh that
that means that you can do kind of zero
shot uh label predictions where you have
a photo of uh and then you need to
figure out what uh the right label is
for a given image using this kind of
prompt right so the the thing you know
you probably all know about prompting
large language models and so you can
prompt vision and language models in in
very much the same way and do zero shot
generalization
um so if you want a really really good
paper I would recommend that you read
this paper this is really one that's
going to teach you how to write really
good papers it's thorough and it's
really worth a very close read I think
if you're interested in this view
um and so I think when it came out uh
actually on imagenet itself it it didn't
really outperform resnet right so so you
might think oh yeah actually it's not
all that special but what really made it
special was that it generalized much
better to these other data sets right so
this uh this resnet thing here is pretty
terrible at some of these kind of
adversarial versions of imagenet and
clip is super robust to that so it's
just a way better image encoder in
general
um so uh very very quickly after clip
there was this paper from Google uh
using a line
um which was basically exactly the same
idea uh you know the field is not really
that creative at all it's like the same
idea but then you just keep like
throwing more data and more compute at
it and it often works much better so
that's what they found here too and 1.8
billion image taxpayers instead of 300
million gives you a better model
surprise
um but uh so it's still very cool and
and what is really cool I think is that
there's this organization called lion
um uh where uh they've they've started
this open source Collective to create
really high quality data sets
um and so the lie on the initial data
set
um was uh how many examples in the
initial lineup
400 million right he knows I know that
he knows
um and uh so so now there's a much
bigger version of lion uh that's even
multilingual and it has five billion
examples right so uh stable diffusion
was trained on sort of the image the
English subset of this thing uh and
that's one of the reasons that it's so
awesome it's because it's just seen a
ton of data uh and that really makes
your system a lot better so if you're
looking for like the ultimate data set
to play around with uh with your own
ideas if you have enough compute
obviously then you should really look at
this data set
all right any questions about
up until this point
nope all right
um so that then we'll we'll move on from
late Fusion to kind of middle Fusion
early Fusion uh and this really is kind
of the core uh of what I think a lot of
people in the field right now or if
you're interested in getting in this
field or if you're going to go into
industry and you're going to be using
this stuff like this is what you should
really understand and and
again like the idea is sort of Stack
onto each other so I've kind of uh
sequenced the slides to give you an idea
sort of of how the scientists kind of
came up with the next step uh and you
can really see the architecture just get
slightly more and more advanced but
basically a lot of it is just more data
and more compute uh again
um so uh who knows how bird works
everybody should raise their heads so
um
uh yeah so so Bert is kind of so
canonical I think everybody kind of gets
out Burke works right so I don't think
we need a real refresher uh but uh I
think you can think and so the reason I
have to slide is because I want you to
think about if you have a bird model
and you have a bunch of images how are
you going to turn that Bird model into
something multimodal
right so so there are a bunch of like
obvious things you could do given the
kind of features I told you about in the
sort of fusion process so you know how
are you going to do that
does anybody want to like
say something
like if you're doing classification
and then just concatenate it to whatever
encoder like maybe an a n or whatever
you're training on the data
concatenating okay exactly yeah so so
you can take take the confnet features
and classifier token from bird
concatenate them and then classify uh
for like a catheter or something like
that or whatever the thing is you're
interested in yeah
yeah so that's one thing you could also
like take the confident features and
like give them to the bird model in lots
of different ways right uh we can use
the region features so
um and I think a lot of people uh when
Burke came out who were working in in
vision and language processing were
thinking exactly about okay so do we do
like middle Fusion late Fusion do we do
early Fusion how do we do diffusion
um and so there were a lot of papers all
coming out basically at around the same
time where people were doing versions uh
of this because so Bert was really kind
of the Innovation and then everybody
sort of just plugged it into their own
thing because of hugging face
Transformers and things like that so
um the first thing is uh visual bird
um this was one of the very early ones
where you have this image and people
would do uh object detection on this so
you get like a hat and a racket and a
shirt and things like that so you can
just really take these features and then
plug them into your uh your Transformer
model and then you you try to like
recover the features and so this really
is probably like the simplest way to do
it right
um and so this is what we call a single
stream architecture where you have all
of these kind of concatenating the the
original input features and then putting
them through the same Transformer what
you can also do and that's something
that this this uh model called vilbert
did is where you have two different
streams so you essentially have these
two parallel Transformers but at every
layer uh you kind of give them a cross
attention right so or co-attention as
they call it but it's basically like so
you just make sure you have an attention
map that spends both and then you just
do your full normal Transformer layer
again
um and then so this you can train just
like your regular Bird right so you uh
you have your your masked model Mass
language model here and here you do sort
of some equivalent of that and then you
also have your next sentence prediction
which you probably remember from your
birth lecture
um but instead here we're saying okay is
this image aligned with this piece of
text or not
um there's also lexmart I mean there I
could go on forever there are like 100
papers that that came out that did this
all at the same time so Lexmark had a
different cross-modal output encoder a
bunch of different uh ways of encoding
the positional information right so you
could say okay I just have a bunch of
bounding boxes that are featureized but
I don't care about where they are in the
image so it's just kind of like a just a
bag of uh bounding boxes or you could
say I found it here like this is the
particular like top left and and bottom
right coordinate and that's what you
featurize into your network
um you can also do something even dumber
and I can say that because this is my
paper
um where you just take the the image
itself you put it through a resnet and
then you uh do a little bit of pooling
on the final feature maps and you just
get give those feature Maps too Bert
um and so you then need to distinguish
between like your text segment
embeddings right and your vision segment
embeddings
um but so this actually works
surprisingly well you don't have to do
any uh any additional training you can
just take Bert out of the box initially
you freeze it you learn to project into
bird token space then you unfreeze your
resnet and then finally you unfreeze
your birth and now you have a very good
multimodal classifier on the problem you
care about so a lot of these other
papers they're doing what they call
multimodal pre-training where first you
have a bird model and a resnet so
they're kind of unimodally pre-trained
and then you couple them together and
then you have a multimodal sort of
intermediate every pre-training step
before you fine tune it on the problem
you care about uh and what we showed
here is that you don't really need that
actually in many cases so it's a very
strong Baseline
um you can also go to the the pixel
level completely so so that's what they
they did in this other paper called
pixel bird where they it's basically
exactly mmbt uh so the the previous uh
supervised one but here they do do the
the multimodal pre-training step and
show that I think for vqa it helps a
little bit
um so there are many of these birds uh
doing sort of visual things uh people
really tried everything uh here's
another one called unider where they
they added a bunch of different losses
uh we can really talk about this for a
very long time uh We're not gonna do
that I'm just gonna kind of talk you
through some of the more interesting
ones so this one I think is quite
interesting built because here this is
really the first instance where we are
completely gone from uh confident
features so we don't do any any
pre-processing on the image no regime
features no backbone that it featurizes
the uh the the parts of the image we
care about we just have these patches of
the image so really integrate we
flattened those patches we just pump
them into the Transformer straight away
so this really is like sort of burnt and
vit together in one model and this
worked really very well
um so that that's been the trend uh so
here's a here's a nice uh very long list
of all those all of these different
models and what they do and and so
really the distinctions are just in what
is the text encoder that you use so do
you use birth or something fancier or
better Roberta uh what is your vision
encoder so in many cases you have these
region features so you would do an rcnn
style thing or you could just do a
resnet or a vit you have different kinds
of fusion so either single or dual
stream as we talked about right so
visual birth or vilbert different
pre-training tasks so Mass language
modeling image text matching there's a
bunch of like funkier ones you can do so
and then finally you can do multimodal
pre-training on all of these different
data sets that have aligned data um So
you you're probably wondering okay so
what is what is really the interesting
difference between a lot of these and uh
so I have another recommended paper that
if you're interested in this space you
should really take a look at it's also a
really well done paper where uh they uh
they unmask multimodal pre-training so
basically they say
if you take all of these little model
inventions and you train these different
models on exactly the same data in
exactly the same way it turns out that
they're all basically the same
uh so that's a lot of kind of uh you
know wasted effort on the part of the
field because everybody is saying like
oh my model is better but it's actually
just because you trained it on different
data and there's no real sort of model
Innovation uh going on in a lot of these
things so I don't mean to sound
discouraging or anything like that but
you know like uh I think that's why this
paper is really nice and really
important is because it just shows us
what really matters
so this is also work that I I did myself
uh called Flava uh with uh with my team
where we wanted to take these ideas
really to the limit so a lot of the
things that you've seen now uh so the
visual Birds and the vilberts and things
like that they're all about multimodal
questions so how can we do visual
question answering uh something like
that where we just have these two
modalities we only care about problems
that always involve these two modalities
and where we want to go and this is this
is kind of the basic premise I think of
foundation models in general is that we
have one model to rule them all right so
this one model can consume data from all
of these different modalities and you
can synthesize across all of these
different modalities and then do useful
things with that information
um so so with flavor that's exactly what
we tried to build so we wanted to have
one Foundation model that is good at
vision and language and computer vision
and natural language processing is
jointly pre-trained on all of these
different data sources so it's also
trained on just CC news so common all
and book Corpus so it's very good at the
sort of things you would expect Bert to
be good at it's drained on imagenet for
image data so it's good at the things
that you would expect is a kind of basic
image model to be good at and then you
have this PMD data set that we created
out of publicly available uh image text
pairs that we also train it on so this
PMD data set is really just if you take
all the data sets that were ever created
that have image text pairs that are
publicly available so unfortunately the
clip data and the Google Align data and
all of these data sets they haven't been
open source so this is before rely on uh
where so now there's a good alternative
to this
um but so this PMD data set
if you combine all of these image
taxpayers you get 70 million of them so
that's still pretty decent size and then
you can take all of this data basically
to solve all of these problems that we
know we care about in these different
fields so you can do multimodal
reasoning you can do language
understanding you can do visual
recognition all with exactly the same
model and that's that's a very powerful
idea I think if you uh like if you work
at a company like Facebook you don't
want to have different models for all
kinds of different things you want to
have one model that you can really use
for everything that's going to really
make your life a lot easier
um so the exact architecture here is
that on the one hand we have this image
encoder where we take the image we
encoded as patches and we just do what
we call mass image modeling but it's
basically Mass language modeling and
then just on the on the image tokens
right
uh and then on the other side we have
the mass language modeling uh on on the
language so your regular sort of bird
thing and then we have a multimodal part
where all of this information gets
combined uh so we have a mass multimodal
modeling loss term uh where you can also
do image text matching so this is like
your bird next sentence prediction thing
and then we also have a global
contrastive loss which is exactly like a
clip so if you do all of this stuff it's
just all Transformers all the way down
and it's sort of a very elegant way I
think to combine a lot of this
information
um and when you do that you get
something that can really do a lot of
things very well uh so I'm we're not
going to talk about that table is just
way too many numbers but uh so just
trust me we were pretty thorough
generating uh the table here and so over
35 different tests if you compare flavor
to all kinds of different ablations in
terms of clip models then this is just a
much better way to to get to this
information
so I think this is a nice example of
like where we're probably going to go
with the field uh in in the near future
um so the other Trend that we that we
see very obviously in the field right
now is that everybody cares about
generative models right so you know
language models and and you know image
generative models there's just a trend
where we want to be generative we want
to move away from this contrastive
discriminative uh stuff to the more
interesting more richer representations
maybe that you get out of generating
sequences or or images
um so this uh Sim vlm paper was one of
the first ones where they really had
this separate decoder that was trying to
generate or kind of complete captions
which they showed gives you a lot richer
representations
um I think this is actually the current
state of the art now it's called coca
so a lot of these uh models they all
again look very similar uh but in this
case now we're starting to really see
these text decoders so initially with
clip I think that's also what they were
trying to go for like open AI being a
company that really likes generative
models but they couldn't really get it
to work and I think so it took us a
while as a field to really figure out
how to do this the right way
um and so right now we're really kind of
in the age of language models right and
uh so uh one of the interesting things
you can do with language models is just
keep them Frozen and then learn how to
project into the language models so uh
the mmbt architecture I talked about
where we had this bird model we kind of
kept it frozen and we learned to learn
to project into the bird token space you
can do exactly the same thing but then
with a much fancier model uh or
something like T5 even where you just
have an encoder decoder or some kind of
generative part of this you keep that
thing Frozen uh and then you learn to
project into the token space of that
Frozen language model uh and then you
can do lots of fun stuff it turns out so
what they show in this paper is that you
then get few shot Learners uh so all of
the things you see with gpt3 where you
can just give it some kind of in-context
examples and it's gonna figure out
binding uh kind of on the fly so it says
like this is a accent this is a blicket
so what is what is this and then it
gives you the answer that is that it's
the decks so it really learns in context
how you decide the feature mappings
which is really kind of solving the the
grounding problem that a lot of this
multimodal stuff uh started with
so I think that's very cool and then uh
probably one of the the coolest papers
right now or models right now that you
might have heard of if you follow the
field is flamingo uh out of deepmind
where they take a chinchilla language
model
um and uh so this is really an optimal
language model and now you have this
Vision encoder uh that encodes multiple
different images uh that you can then do
reasoning over and then kind of
autocomplete so what this gets you is
just a much more powerful model because
you can do uh you know your generative
over lots of different images so like
it's really like step wise you can see
it right we started off with very simple
Transformers and now we're actually at
something that that is starting to get
pretty complicated because we have these
building blocks like a perceiver
resampler where we have a a bunch of
different images that we featureize and
now we need to compress the information
because sometimes we have three images
sometimes we have five images so we want
to make sure that we can compress it so
that it's always ready for consumption
and by the next layer of the language
model and then so this paper again is a
really good paper to read because they
actually so this is not me this is not
my code this comes from the actual paper
so they just have the diagram together
with the code so that you can really
understand what it's doing which I think
is is really uh great
um and so once you you have your
perceiver resampling step what you then
do is you do a gated cross attention
this is how you implement it
um and uh so this gated cross attention
you do that before your Frozen language
model layer so you really just have a
frozen chinchilla language model and you
learn to kind of modulate the
information that goes into that language
model you propagate the gradients all
the way back you just don't update the
language model so you're really kind of
trying to figure out like how am I going
to design my signal so that my language
model can can do the most with it right
how am I going to combine the
information so you'll notice that now we
do it before the layer right in a lot of
other stuff you would do the attention
after the layer but here you do it
before
um so uh karpathy I think more than 10
years ago had this this image it's
Barack Obama kind of setting his foot
here on the scale to make somebody think
uh like uh you know they're they're a
lot heavier than they really are uh so
this is obviously funny to us
um but not to an AI system I think
unless it really uh understands the
scene and so that's why karpathy uh at
the time said this would be a really
good visual Turing test like if a system
can figure this out then it's actually
really smart
um and so obviously it's been a bit of a
challenge for everybody working in the
field than to get something that
actually works on this and uh so
Flamingo as it turns out kind of gets
the joke
um but uh yeah so it's it's a bit
unclear if it really gets the joke
because if you read this conversation
it's sort of kind of getting steered in
the right direction right but
um at least we're making progress let's
put it that way
um and then so in Flamingo you still
have a lot of moving Parts but you can
really take this almost through the full
extreme where you try to freeze almost
everything and you just want to learn
this kind of mapping between your image
encoder and your language model or your
image encoder and your encoder decoder
architecture and all you really do is
just the projection between the two
right so there's this nice model called
blip 2 where they they experiment with
like opt for the language model in Flint
T5 for the encoder decoder architecture
and this just gives you amazing results
it gives you uh really complex captions
and things like that without any real
direct supervision on the captions
itself which is pretty impressive I
think so that just shows you the power
of language models in general
um so here are some examples uh so it
can really do like different things from
captioning to reasoning to visual
question answering to like like location
detection uh so you can have a long
conversation with this system this
really is is kind of the future where
we're going right where we're going to
have a chat GPT but it's also going to
be able to see the world in a way
um and so so I think an interesting
thing so you've probably heard of like
Chain of Thought prompting and things
like that where you ask the language
model like let's think step by step
um and you can tell a vision and
language model uh generate a rationale
for why uh why something might be the
case so you generate a potential
explanation for what your answer might
be and then after that you ask it to
answer the question and it turns out
that if you do that sort of multimodal
Chain of Thought prompting then the
system gets much better uh and and so
you know this was like the new
state-of-the-art on science QA or
Benchmark like that just because it
learns to unpack the information right
and so uh I think we're really as a
field just starting to figure out what
what the potential is of this and I
think this paper is where they also
showed that multimodal Chain of Thought
prompting really gets you pretty amazing
results and they show uh very nice
results on Raven matrices and like very
complicated kind of IQ tests the things
that that humans are supposed to be
really good at but you have to be a
pretty smart human to really be good at
this and this system Just Nails it
um so you know we're making super fast
progress and we started off from a very
simple birth model that was able to look
at some pictures and now we're getting
to these very sophisticated Foundation
models so that was my my short history
of multimodal foundation models
um so how much time do I have left
all right okay plenty of time
um
yeah please questions
one of the images they just looked like
they were
um boxes
passed through and kind of no sense of
shape in them yeah yeah so so I I think
the the history of computer vision has
been very similar to the history of
natural language processing where we
thought we needed all of this structure
and all of these different things and it
turns out you can just throw it all away
and just have a big Transformer over the
patches
sorry yes
[Laughter]
you mentioned a couple times like Model
T person or what does that mean yeah uh
yeah sorry I should have explained that
better maybe so it just means that um we
are not updating the weights
um so uh like if we go to uh this era I
think is a nice example so uh we have
frozen self-attention so that just means
that we when we do a forward pass we go
all the way to whatever we want to
predict we get some gradients we take
them all the way down but we only update
the non-frozen layers right so here the
gradients actually do get updated but
these just never change and so the
reason you want to do that is because
otherwise you're going to drift way too
far right so then you're going to kind
of destroy all of the cool stuff your
language model has learned because
you're just going to focus on on the
small data set that you're training it
on so you want to preserve the abilities
of the language model but you want it to
become good at the thing you care about
other questions
is there a benefit to doing like that
really your Metal Fusion as opposed to
like only doing leg Fusion I think yeah
so so I mean we're going to talk about
evaluation next but so it really depends
on the the tasks that you care about
um and so I would say the earlier is
always the better if you can afford it
uh and so like clip is very efficient to
train it's very late Fusion right at the
very end so there's no interaction
between the different modalities
um and so that's really good if you want
to be very efficient and if you want to
be like for training it's it's much
nicer right uh but if you want to have a
richer understanding of the the
multimodal signal then you want to do
earlier Fusion
so it's yeah it's always a trade-off
right
images are just a lot more data than
text so how much more difficult are
these to train and um how much bigger
does like the image processing have to
be compared to uh the language model
yeah so so
um images are are more complex in a way
but but they're also kind of higher
bandwidth representations right so
there's a lot of kind of like just
pixels that our brains just abstract
away right it's really about the scene
that you're seeing and like you're not
really
thinking too much about the pixels
themselves
um so so like John Lagoon likes to say
that uh language is just a kind of low
bandwidth uh a proxy for a language of
thought which is much richer and much
higher bandwidth and like he thinks
probably visual I'm not so sure
um but uh so uh yeah I I don't think
that there's necessarily a difference
between kind of the scaling laws that
you see in these systems
um or at least we still have to figure
that out we'll kind of talk about that
towards the end as well
so how
to put your bias just like the natural
one oh yeah they have terrible biases
yeah
um so yeah so some people are actually
working on on this uh who are in this
very room but uh so these models can be
very racist also in what they generate
or or the kind of predictions they make
so uh if you have an Asian basketball
player standing sort of like this with a
basketball very obviously there then the
model will think that he's playing ping
pong because he's Asian I'm not joking
so uh
so so these models uh yeah just like all
neural networks right this is really a
big problem and one of the the most
interesting problems that that you
should be working on if you're a student
and you want to make a difference is how
do we get these systems to be much
better at these sorts of things
probably examples you show like the
model interpret from the content of the
image so really we want to understand
the content for a video so what actual
challenges you might see like what
improvements we can make uh to um
yeah so so
um you're asking about the attention
Mass sort of right yeah so you can use
the same idea for for videos uh and you
just look at the video and and so these
systems are are so good now the object
detectors are so good you can really
track objects kind of real time as they
they go through your video and so you
can try to check how that aligns with
your attention mask in your model
um so so a lot of uh like so videos I
think are sort of interesting but
they're also not really interesting
because you can very often just
sub-sample images and solve the images
rather than having to deal with the
complex video
um good job
all right maybe one more one more
question and then we'll go do some
evaluations yeah so these multi-mole
models when um you only provide let's
say you only provide a single source of
media to the same only text or vision
how does it perform in that case because
it's obviously more geared for
multi-million cases yeah so I mean
that's one of the giant shortcomings of
a lot of these models is that they're
really just built for multimodal stuff
and so what if I don't have an image
right uh and so uh I mean that that's
why we did Flavor because we want to
have one model that can do all of that
stuff
um and that's why in in mmbt so the
supervised multimodal by Transformer we
actually have an analysis of like how
robust is this model to missing images
or missing text uh but uh so I think a
lot of a lot of folks working on these
early visual bird models that were kind
of myopically focused on vqa uh which is
actually a great segue to what I want to
talk about next uh so so it really
depends on the the tasks that you care
about as I said right and so I I think
if I'm gonna tell you about
multimodality I also have to tell you
how you're going to check that the
multimodal system is actually good at
multimodal things and so that's the the
topic of evaluation which actually is a
super important topic and a lot of
people they want to be cool and build
big models uh but I I think it should be
way cooler to do proper evaluation of
these models especially if you're in
Academia because you only have limited
gpus anyway right so what what what can
you do
sorry I don't want to rub it in with it
no
um so um so how do you check well um
there's this amazing project uh so like
imagenet really changed like the history
of deep learning I think and this other
data set Coco I think also really
changed especially vision and language
but also I think Vision uh in general
where they uh have just a bunch of main
sort of multimodal tasks so these images
are very richly annotated with all kinds
of different things so like the
segmentation of the objects the bounding
boxes the labels of the boundary boxes
they come with like uh sort of a
different pixel granularities it's a
huge data set uh it's very fine-grained
uh annotated in terms of like the
categories that it has and then you have
five captions for each of these images
um and so this this really was the first
data set that unlocked a lot of sort of
vision and language processing at scale
because you had your picture and you had
your caption and now you need to figure
out okay how do I give the right caption
for this image so that's image
captioning or can I retrieve given some
piece of text the right image or the
piece of uh or the image for the piece
of text so there's a bunch of very
impactful data sets that do this stuff
that we already talked about lion but
Coco really is the main one still I
think that a lot of people kind of use
as the canal core instance of this data
set category
and then the other thing that people
really care about in vision and language
processing is visual question answering
um and so the there really are a bunch
of academic groups who are or have been
so focused on this task that they didn't
really care about anything else and
that's why you see a lot of models that
are really optimized just for multimodal
and nothing else uh and you can see that
kind of reflected in the citation counts
as of last night 3 A.M
um where uh so the vqh just has way more
citations than uh image captioning data
sets even right and so what you do here
is you just have an image and then
people ask very simple questions so
annotators right they they ask these
simple questions they give the answers
and now we want to be able to answer
these questions with machines and as I
alluded to earlier one of the the kind
of embarrassing uh backstories of this
data set was that the initial version of
the data set was actually found to uh to
have images not really matter at all so
you could just look at the question then
it could have something like how many
slices of pizza are there
um and so well not in that particular
case but in almost all of the data set
the right answer for how much or how
many questions was too
so if you just predicted two to every
how much or how many questions you got
like 70 accuracy on the accounting
category so careful data set uh or
evaluation Benchmark design is also
really a skill and you really need to
think about what you're doing you can't
just like set some data aside and
evaluate it on it you have to really
think about what you're doing
um and so there's gqa by by Chris
actually which is also just a I I think
a a better designed version of this data
set maybe so you might want to use that
uh these days
um they're also kind of
um a very targeted data sets that really
try to measure one particular thing and
I think one of the things we really want
to get at with these models is what we
would call compositionality right so we
want to be able to really take the parts
and and reason about the whole and
understand the relationships between the
different concepts so clever was a very
clever data set uh that was designed
really to to measure the the
compositionality both on the language
side and on the vision side so you have
to understand the relationships between
all of these different objects in the
images uh so that's been a pretty
impactful data set I think for really uh
forcing people to think about
compositionality
but a lot of these data sets uh really
had big problems uh so so one of the
problem is you know uh they were too
easy uh so vqa is sort of like
plateauing out we can talk about that a
little bit too it wasn't really
realistic so you could solve vqa and
that's probably going to make some
people's lives better you're all like
trying to process the means how I can
see everything
okay let's get to the memes first then
so
um so uh obviously so these memes are
not actually in the data set
um so I could put some really hateful
memes about sort of Hitler or something
which are in the data set but that would
be less fun
um so uh these are mean meme examples to
kind of uh demonstrate uh how the data
set was constructed and and so one of
the problems we had as I said like vqa
the V didn't really matter what we want
to have is a data set if we're if we
care about multimodality specifically
it's like how do we get a data set that
you can only get right if you are good
at multimodal reasoning and otherwise
you're just going to screw it up
um and so this is what we came up with
is if you have a meme like this one love
the way you smell today I mean that's
not very nice if you send this to your
friend right
um
so
um but uh so it turns out that that if
you just swap out the background now
it's a very nice thing to say right uh
and like this one is you know I don't
know you're maybe a bit weird if you
like this but uh there's there's nothing
wrong with it right
um and so it's the same for this one
here like look how many people love you
with the Tumbleweed that's really sad
and like you know if you if you if you
change just one word suddenly it's like
a really nice thing to say right
um so so if you want to solve this if
you want to classify this correctly for
the meanness
then you have to really understand
multimodal reasoning you have to
understand the relationship between the
image and the text in order to get to
the right label right and so it was
really constructed by Design to do that
um and uh so how we did it exactly is we
we use some really uh highly trained
annotators and then uh one of the big
problems with a lot of these data sets
is that uh nobody really knows who owns
the meme for example right so somebody
makes this meme now they technically own
a copyright and so when I made this data
set I was working at the Facebook and
they were very afraid of copyright
things so what we actually had to do is
uh we had to pay people to make new
memes
um
and and so so not from stretch so we
could show them kind of the actual
examples and then they had to try to
find images that were were uh kind of
corresponding to the original Source
image and tried to recreate the meme but
now with an image that we could buy from
Getty
um and and so we gave a lot of money to
Getty uh so that we could then release
the data set uh to the public so that
people could do actually research on
this and understand for their multimodal
models whether they're good or not
um and so we really tried to make it so
that we had these benign co-founder
benign confounders uh sorry um it's a
startup world with co-founders
um so um so the co-founder here is
obviously that you have your original
Meme and then you have uh your
confounder where you swap out one of the
modalities in here you have the other
one right so we had our annotators do
that as well uh and so this led to a
really nice data set I think uh because
it showed some of the intuitions that I
think a lot of people under field had
which is that multimodal pre-training
doesn't really work
is that an alarm
um so multimodal pre-training doesn't
really work uh and so all of this stuff
that people have been doing with all
their fancy visual work models actually
turned out maybe to not really be that
useful anyway and so maybe it got you
like one point extra right from visual
birth to like a different visual birth
like less than a point uh just just by
doing that multimodal pre-training
um so that means like we still have to
figure this stuff out right this this
data set is far from Salt and we we
still have a long way to go despite all
of these fancy models and and you know a
new paper coming out every week that
does something new like we're not there
yet
um and I think that's encouraging uh
especially for you like when you uh you
can go out and solve it
um so
um what we did with this data set is we
organized the competition we had 100K in
price money uh to try to see what people
could come up with
um and so there there was a lot of nice
work coming out of that and we've really
kind of managed to to crank the numbers
up by quite a lot
um but the the solutions were slightly
disappointing so I don't know if you've
ever used kaggle but if you want to
really win on kaggle you just have to
Ensemble the hell out of all of the
different models that are in the current
state of the art and then you're very
likely to win right and so that's that's
what happened here
um where you know there wasn't really
the fundamental breakthrough we had
maybe been hoping for so uh that still
uh needs to be built I think
um so this other data set I just want to
kind of briefly talk about so so the
theme sort of of this section is like if
you make a data set think about it very
carefully uh because you can really be
very creative with this and really
really measure the things you're trying
to get at so
um this this data set winner ground we
were trying to figure out okay how good
is clip actually so it looks really
amazing and it's way better than things
that were previously there but does it
understand compositional relationships
in the same way that humans would
understand it or is it sort of just
fitting onto the data distribution and
it can be very good at the head of the
distribution but it's terrible at detail
and you can probably already guess where
this is going
um but uh so so just to give you an
illustration of what is in this data set
you would have some plants surrounding a
light bulb or you would have eight light
bulb surrounding some plants so notice
that the words here are exactly the same
words
but in a different order right so uh and
and so the visual depiction of these
words is very very different so if your
model your contrastive model is actually
good at understanding the Visio semantic
or the yeah visual linguistic
compositionality uh of these these uh
these uh examples then then you can get
it right but again if it's actually just
overfitting on the data distribution
that is seen and it just kind of is
biased toward what it sees often then it
doesn't really get it right and so one
paper uh that we use as a source of
inspiration for this work is uh this
paper here Order word matters
pre-training for little uh so we
actually found that the order of words
doesn't even matter that much for
General pre-training very often uh which
is also kind of a scary thing right so
this is deep learning for NLP we think
that you know language is really
important but these models can can
reason about language even if you
shuffle all the words
um and so that's that's probably not
what we want to have and so that that
doesn't tell you something about how
great we are as researchers it tells you
something about how terrible our
evaluation benchmarks are right and
that's what we need to fix
um so so what we did with this data set
here some other nice examples like
there's a mug in some grass or there's
some grass in a mug like these are very
different pictures right and so for us
these are trivial like so like you know
what's the difference between a truck
fire and a fire truck
they're pretty pretty important I think
also to get that distinction right
um so um
guess what
um state-of-the-art models often perform
below random chance
so uh uh you know as I said we still
have a lot of work to do which is good
um and and so when this paper came out
that I I think the the reaction was was
really nice and uh so when dolly two
came out
um which so you've probably heard of
Dolly too right so it's sort of like
stable diffusion but then before stable
diffusion
um and so this was really the the first
model that really showed like just how
impressive these generative models can
be uh when they're when they're creating
images so this is there's a mug in some
grass uh you do have to kind of cheat a
little bit because you have to add
digital art here uh if you if you don't
add that then it breaks down completely
right uh so it's sort of prone attacking
I think or sort of tuning on the test
set but okay you know
um so this is pretty good right so so
it's definitely is better than I think a
lot of people would have expected even a
couple of years ago
um but it's not perfect because uh
people on the internet like to take more
pictures of spoons than Forks
um so if you say there are fewer uh
spoons than Forks or there are fewer
Forks than spoons it just really like
spoons more
um you know and so maybe it's like the
Matrix or something I don't know but so
uh
spoons are just nicer
so uh so again what you can see here is
that these models really are just
reflections of the data that they're
trained on right
um and uh yeah so models are getting
better but if you've looked at stable
diffusion like it still can't count
fingers and things like that right so
again uh there's still a lot of a cool
work to be done
any questions on evaluation
no okay so let's let's talk about other
modalities then because so we've really
just been focused on images and images
are great there are lots of images uh on
the internet and and so that makes it
sort of an obvious thing to focus on
it's also I think if you look at our
brain like vision is a very dominant
modality right so how we understand the
world is very Vision driven uh but it
that it that doesn't have to be the case
so there's all these other interesting
problems that involve different
modalities and so the most obvious one
is just speech or audio right so after
after CN comes hearing
um and and really we could do another
lecture just like this just on speech
and audio and there's lots of
interesting stuff to talk about
obviously we don't have time but uh I'll
give you another uh nice example of how
Amazing Alec Radford is at creating data
sets
um so so there's this whisper model that
came out of open AI not too long ago
which was trained on 680 000 hours of
multilingual multitask uh Speech data so
speech with transcriptions
um and they they trained this very fancy
uh thing on there which actually is not
very fancy at all it's just the long
male spectrogram so how you represent
the audio signal and then you feed that
into a big Transformer so this is sort
of your encoder self-attention here
right and then you have your decoder
where you have your cross attention and
then you just generate the sequence so
this is encoder decoder basic
Transformer model but your input is uh
convolutions one-dimensional
convolutions over the log mail
spectrogram and so there's lots of
papers that do very similar things uh
there's there's models like wave to VEC
that try to turn the wave signal into
vectors or you can discretize it in lots
of different ways
um so there's a wealth of literature
then I think one of the funny
observations actually is that you can
just reduce audio to Vision anyway right
so so that's what you could sort of
argue this log mail spectrogram does but
so not to toot my own horn but in 27 I I
did this paper where we showed that you
can just take a real audio sample turn
it into a a kind of a spectrogram really
just a spectrogram so what does the
spectrum of the the audio file look like
feed that to a regular content like an
Alex net even and then that gives you
amazing auditory features so now you can
use this to distinguish between violins
or guitars and things like that so you
know maybe you can just reduce all of
this to Vision so one question maybe you
could ask is that can we also reduce
language division
or Vision to language
you know that could so that's sort of
what people are thinking about today
um so we talked about the video there
was a question about video so a lot of
these ideas also extend pretty directly
to video but now you just have more data
right so like Flamingo already had a
bunch of different images in it you can
do Flamingo over videos probably a lot
of the images are pretty useless for
what you're trying to do with this video
model right so they're they're too
similar it doesn't really add all that
much information so you want to
sub-sample the frames so that you get
the most useful information out of your
video uh and so there's a bunch of
approaches that that kind of take the
keyframes and then you just do a
standard joint vision and language
Transformer encoder thing on top of that
so this is kind of becoming hopefully by
now a very familiar recipe right
um and so there's this so Merlot is a
nice architecture that does this and
then they came up with Merlot Reserve
kind of a silly name where they also
added audio to this model so this is now
a tri-modal model right and so you know
for going towards this Foundation model
that can consume all of these different
modalities uh all in one go and that's
really like a clear Trend in the field
um another very interesting Direction I
think where in the field we were very
excited about this for a while but we I
think it's it's sort of uh gone now
because it's too difficult to create
lots of high quality data in this
setting but what you can do is you can
have simulated environments uh so this
is a paper from deepmind from 2017 where
they had this agent walk around in the
Maze and then it could have natural
language instructions they could also
generalize to like decks and Blicks and
different sort of groundings to the and
assignments that that you could do in
that environment so this is a super
interesting Direction I think in the
long term because this is how humans
learn language right like we walk around
in the world we interact with our
environments we have all of these
different perceptual observations we
synthesize them in our brain we
manipulate objects we change our own
Viewpoint and that's how we learn
everything we know about the world and
so our our language is very intricately
connected to that world and how we
observe it
um so I think that that might make a
comeback at some point in the future
um you can also do other stuff so
especially with this kind of
conditioning or text that that we're
seeing a lot of right so like so you
know Dali 2 and stable diffusion and all
of these different things and the
original again we talked about at the
beginning you can do the same thing but
now you're generating 3D Point clouds
right so this is a 3D Corgi
um using a corgi and so this this prompt
can probably become much more complex
over time and you can do like sort of
AutoCAD design and just say like give me
a house and it's just going to design
the whole house for you uh so you can
just like tweak The Prompt and things
like that like that that's all coming or
or even already here in many cases
um so so the final modality I I just
briefly wanted to talk about is uh
olfactory embeddings
sure
um and uh so olfaction means smell if
you didn't know
um and uh so it turns out so my PhD
thesis was about grounding uh semantics
in uh different perceptual modalities so
a lot of my work started in vision and
then it's like okay now audio is sort of
the obvious next one right so you can
learn the meaning of violin and then
maybe you can learn that violin like
what a violin looks like and what it is
and what it sounds like and that's going
to give you a richer representation but
for a lot of these words well it's
actually very primitive to their meaning
is what they smell like because uh in
our brains that's really one of the core
areas of one of the oldest areas in your
brain uh so uh what you can try to do if
you want to complete all of your
perceptual modalities is you can try to
build olfactory embedding so it was kind
of a joke paper I did but
um the funny thing is it actually worked
um so uh there's there's a catalog this
Sigma Aldrich fine flavors and
fragrances catalog where you can look up
words like melon and pineapple and then
it's going to give you all of the
chemical compounds that produce this
smell or taste and so if you do that
then you can count the occurrences and
then you can sort of do SVD or something
like that only to to get it to be a bit
more of a real embedding model so now
you get smell embeddings smell vectors
and then you can compute similarity
judgments between these these smell so
turns out Apple smells like pear uh and
you know the chocolate and cocoa and
sweet and coffee are sort of related
right so you get these clusters of
different smells just based off of their
chemical compounds so this bag of
chemical compounds model gives you a
very rich representation and so if you
look at all of the words that are
concrete enough to have smell right so
like if you have a word like democracy
in there that doesn't really smell like
anything right so you you ignore
democracy and you just focus on on the
things that smell
um or that good smell I guess
um and then so the the really
interesting thing to me is that you know
this is is much more correlated with
human similarity judgments than the
linguistic vectors we had at the time
right so so for a work like apple like
you can just get a word Vector like
you've learned in your first lecture uh
and and so you can do like you know Skip
gram and things like that but that that
thing is not going to be as correlated
with human similarity judgments as this
bag of chemical compounds model
so that's that's pretty interesting
right so even something like smell where
maybe we think you know this doesn't
really matter if you really want to
understand how humans understand
language then maybe you want to include
this in your foundation model too
and but I would start with other
modalities
all right
um
okay yeah sorry yeah uh so where to next
uh I'll just I think I've already said
most of this actually so One Foundation
model is going to rule them all
um and we'll so I mean there will be
many of these but a lot of them are
going to have very similar traits I
think
um we're going to be looking at scaling
loss and trying to understand really
what is the relationship between the
different modalities which one do we
want more of that sort of stuff
we're going to have retrieval
augmentation this thing is going to be
really huge if you've heard of rag or if
you haven't you should look it up uh so
all of these parts of these models can
also be multimodal we need way better
evaluation and better measurements we
already talked about that too and that's
all I have thank you
[Applause]